hello and welcome back to
chessopenings.com and Lachman normally
teaches this class but it is staying
home today today I wanted to go over an
opening that I picked up over the past
year so called the red Gozen it's a very
interesting line for black against the
Queen's Gambit which allows black to
both fight for a very tactical game and
equalize very equal very quickly and
very easily
if white doesn't apply too much pressure
so to start with let me just show you
the first few moves
it starts with d4 and now of course
there are actually a few move orders you
can use to get there the move order I
use is to start with one Knight f6 now
after c4 and a six
there are a variety of ways white can
play the two most common Knight c3 and
Knight f3 go into different lines of the
Queen's Gambit Knight c3 is a pretty
common choice at the top level and after
d5 the fact that white has developed
this Knight to c3 gives them a bit more
options in this opening for example C
takes d5 a takes d5 and now since white
has not developed this night on g1 later
after some moves like am Bishop g5 and
III and Bishop d3 this - action this
night might actually come to the e2
square rather than the f3 square the
downside to this of course is that it
allows the Bishop b4 nimzo-indian
defense which of course has a very good
reputation reputation it's very solid
very nice for black to play to get a
good equal game so if Knight c3 is on
the board and you do happen to play d5
you can still get into their chosen but
I just wanted to mention this little
fact about the position here and in fact
the rosin I'm sorry would be difficult
to achieve
if white does go for one of these
exchange lines Bishop b4 here isn't
quite as well respected as
riggo's in so with that in mind after
Knight c3 I would recommend going into
the nihms oh this is what I do in my own
repertoire but the move d5 is perfectly
fine as well
with that in mind though Knight f3 is
now actually the more common move that I
see and that is actually seen at the top
level I think and the reason for that is
it avoids this nimzo-indian which is
really annoying but what it does allow
is after d5 now white will play Knight
c3 most often and now of course you can
get into the rigo's and with Bishop b4
this is the starting position of the
ragazze and defense you pin this knight
on c3 White has already developed this
Knight to f3 and black has already
played d5 this is how its kind of
distinct from the nimzo-indian and to
start us off here I wanted to take a
look at this game between Wesley so and
magnus carlsen which is pretty much as
close to a perfect game of chess as you
can get and of course ended in a draw
but I wanted to include this game to
show you how in the main lines black
just equalizes very very easily if white
doesn't try to shake things up a little
bit and make it interesting
the most common move in there goes in is
actually to start with Bishop g5 here
we'll take a look at some other options
for white later on now I'm gonna
recommend h6 for black it's the most
common move and because white has not
included C takes d5 Bishop takes f6 is
pretty much the only move for it at
least by far the main move here we're
gonna take this piece back with our
queen not fracturing our King side pawns
in this case and now III is the main the
main move Queen a4 check is also
playable there but we're gonna take a
look at that and different move order a
little bit later on now a very natural
play for black black simply castles
you'll see white play move like rook c1
you'll see this a lot in Queens gambit
openings white delays developing this
bishop because then black is going to
capture on c4 gaining a tempo by making
this piece move twice and in fact
because white has played work c1 and not
move the bishop black here really has
nothing better than two
take on seafloor this is the main move
and this really is the move that that
shows that black is going to be
completely equal in this main main line
of the Ragosa
if you don't want to kind of blow things
up in the center and want to keep the
game going black does have a variety of
other options you can bring this rook to
d8 this rook rather you can play a move
like c6 and just support the center play
move like 97 even can even play a move
like knight c6 if you like to try and
challenge the center and what these
moves have in common here these three
moves at least is that you're fighting
for the e5 square and that's really one
of the two main breaks for black and
there we go zone is pushing this pawn
forward to e5 what we'll see in this
game because white has played so non
aggressively will say keeping the Queen
back on d1 playing moves like c1 just
super solid stuff this allows black to
just equalize with the most c5 instead
in the game black captured on d4 on c4
other as I said it's the main move
Bishop takes c4 and now the immediate c5
is really showing that that black has no
problems white can castle and now after
C takes d4 let me see Knight takes d4
and Bishop d7 in this game white played
Queen b3 and now black really just needs
to find one accurate move here to
completely seal seal the deal and call
this game pretty much a dead draw of
course we don't want to lose our b7 pawn
at the same time we're not quite ready
yet
to give up this Bishop on c3 because now
the white pieces do have a bit more
activity and we still have these
problems with b7 so the move black needs
to find as Magnus played in the game is
knight c6 and there are over 60 games
here I think white might have won once
black might have won like once or twice
as well and the rest were all drawn and
the fact is there's just not much to
play for here White's best move is
actually to take on c6 and it might look
like tactically this removes the
defender of de spécial but thankfully
for black we have the move Bishop takes
c3 and with this insertion now
there's really nothing left in this game
white took on b7 Bishop takes c6 is
required to save the bishop trading it
off for the night and now after Bishop
takes b2 it's pretty clear that no one
is going to be able to win this game the
bishops are of opposite colors the pawn
structure is symmetrical and neither
side really has a huge lead in peace
activity here this game continued with
rook c2 rook c8 Queen a4 Rick's c7 and
I'm not even gonna bother to say these
last few moves we're just gonna show him
on the board why I waste my effort on
this game which is so clearly a draw and
they played some more they played some
more they traded the Queen's and then
they repeated moves here and just a fun
side note if you look at this game on LY
chess or anything like that and you you
click the request engine analysis button
it'll say you know something like one
average sent upon loss like this is this
is about as perfect as a chess game gets
meaning neither side really made any
mistakes that is all to say that with
the c5 move this is really going to be
black's equalizing move when white is
playing you know pretty conservatively
against there it goes and you know white
trades off this Bishop on f6 white just
develops those pieces plays a move like
rook c1 to solidify everything that's
when you can go for this move D takes c4
and c5 to solidify everything I do want
to mention it might not be the best idea
to play C 5 immediately in this position
without including D takes c4 of course
this would be great for us if white
played a bad move like Bishop e2 now we
are simply gaining a tempo over the
other line because this Bishop has moved
once but this does allow of course white
to actually capture on d5 and now after
a move like a takes d5 and D takes e5
black is going to be left with this
isolated queen pawn which isn't the
worst ever but there's no reason to
allow any of this when you can just
capture on c4 immediately so that's it
for Game one Wesley so magnus carlsen
- very good chess players agreeing to a
draw
after some good opening play up next I
wanted to take a look at a much more
exciting game between Victor lesnick ax
and Jacques mom and you are off and this
is the game that will hopefully make you
actually like the rigo's in a bit more
it shows that it's not just a tool for
equalizing if there's going to be you
know a battle black is going to have
very good chances to both win the battle
and have a lot of fun doing it so let's
let's see this game they got their of
yeah a slightly different move order one
night of three from white black played
Knight f6 now c4 e6 d4 and d5 and of
course after Knight c3 Bishop before we
arrived at the same starting position in
the previous game we took a look at
Bishop g5 and after age six Bishop takes
f6 in this game we're actually gonna
look at one of the other main options
the third most popular move of course
I'm talking about Queen a4 check and at
first glance this looks slightly awkward
for the black pieces the King is
attacked and the bishop is attacked so
of course there's only one move for
black to save everything you have to
play knight c6 to defend the bishop and
a common principle in chess is that you
don't really want to develop the Knights
in front of the pawns you'll see how
white played first c4 and then Knight c3
and together this knight in this pawn
both control the same squares it really
increases the power of the night here
though black has developed a night in
front of the pawn and now this pawn is
just a little bit stuck on c7 and
keeping in mind the previous game how
black just so quickly equalized with the
pawn break c5 perhaps this is part of
White's idea with Queen a4 check this
night being a slightly misplaced on c6
makes it so that black can't play these
comfortable breaks quite so easily well
see however that this knight on c6 is
not without its own merits as well and
drawing this Queen all the way out to a4
sometimes not always the most
comfortable Square for that Queen either
the game continued with the main line
white simply plays III supporting this
Center
black got it went ahead and got castled
and now it's the Bishop d2 and in the
game black played this move a six which
is not the most common line but it's
certainly one of the most one of the
most well respected lines well one of
the more common lines and the idea with
a six of course is that you're simply
threatening to take on c4 for example if
I move like you know let's say bit
should be - a very bad move D takes c4
Bishop takes c4 you're not actually
threatening to play b5 but you can
continue simply with a move like Bishop
d6 or Bishop d7 and the threat of b5 is
is still going to be there and you're
just keeping these pieces out of this
square as well in the game Queen c2 is
played just bringing this Queen back to
a slightly more natural square its job
has been done on a4 and getting this
Knight out to the awkward c6 square and
that's something you'll see white do a
lot and there goes and actually just
drop this Queen back into a more
comfortable home in the game rook e8 was
black's choice and this is really
proving that the knight on c6 is perhaps
not as misplaced as we first thought
from c6 of course this night is very
quickly controlling the e5 square and
rookie gate aims to take advantage of
that actually
for example if white plays a move like
Bishop e2 now suddenly we might be able
to take on c4 and already break with
this move e5 this is one of the most
common breaks and there it goes and as I
was mentioning earlier c5 or a 5
depending on how white plays and when
white plays like this drawing this
Knight out to c6 controlling the square
e 5 becomes a lot more of a realistic
option in the game white simply plays a3
and in there it goes and we're not super
interested in giving up this Bishop for
this Knight always it was more there to
just kind of temporarily misplaced some
some white pieces put on some
uncomfortable pressure so we're just
gonna drop this Bishop back to d6 now h3
is a common choice from White's it's
just kind of a waiting improving move
guarding the g4 square
and not yet developing this bishop and
not yet committing to C takes d5 which
would allow this Bishop to develop
itself either g4 or even a six now h6
from black aims to do very very similar
things delaying developing this Bishop
waiting for white to take on d5 so that
we have this more natural option of
Bishop to e6
now C takes d5 e takes d5 is played
white couldn't really find any more
improving moves and now Bishop d3 and we
actually don't see Bishop e6 from black
there have been three games in ly chess
database in this position this should be
six was played twice and then in this
game shock mama Yara is the only player
to play the move Bishop d7 and this was
a really interesting idea from shock you
know it on the surface it looks like a
pretty innocuous move you know it's not
really doing much you get the bishop off
the back rank you defend some squares
but it's actually fighting for quite a
lot here and we'll see his idea pretty
quickly here after the move b4 and I
want to say perhaps after b4 black
already might have a slight edge here
due to shock mama drives next move so if
you think you can find shock mom and
yards idea at home here I encourage you
to take a moment try and see if you can
figure out the meaning of this move
Bishop d7 and go ahead pause the video
see if you can do it if not I'm about to
give you the answer so here we go
his idea of course is Knight a seven and
this move is a little bit of a wild one
you know you don't don't often expect to
see Knight a seven but the idea is very
very clear black has put this rook on EA
Tannis knight on f6 and this pawn on d5
he wants to control the e4 square now if
he had put his bishop on e6 this efore
square control would be a little bit you
know less there because it's blocking
his own work off of course and white
would have plenty of pieces covering but
now with this Bishop on d7 the rook
still participates and the bishop also
go
this be 5 square so what we're gonna see
from black is he's aiming for Knight
b-52 shake loose this Knight from c3 and
from there he's going to sink this
knight on to e4 and hope to use this
Knight effectively to gain some kind of
advantage and I really like this idea
from shock and it worked out well for
him in the game
white aimed for Knight a 4 here trying
to sink this knight on to c5 has the
very natural move b6 to prevent this
from happening and now white simply
retreats back to c3 in this maneuver as
well I'm not really in love with 4 for
white here it does waste a lot of time
the goal for white which he actually
achieved was that this pawn is now
backwards and gonna be slightly more
difficult to defend
but this Bishop is currently doing a
very nice job of locking down this c7
upon and I don't think it's really a
huge deal for black and in the end they
probably didn't end up being where at
the time that that White's spent now
shock of course continues with his idea
plays Knight b5 and white plays Knight
d2 to step out of this idea now very
logical chest from shock Mahmoud Yara
Knight e4 follows up and we are starting
to a to leave the opening here but the
key points I wanted to get across in
this opening where one this idea of
waiting with black with h6 is is very
very nice you just save tempo or save a
tempo by not bringing this Bishop out to
d7 just yet kind of holding your cards
back a bit waiting for white to be the
one to commit now if white had wasted
more time with the move like rook d1 now
black might actually go ahead and
capture on c4 and and go in for
something like this rather than allow
white to take on d5 but in the game so
h6 was important and then this Bishop d7
idea I really like you can make use of
this efore square in your own games and
there it goes in like this even if you
don't combine it with this slightly
strange looking Knight a7 to b5 idea so
these are the two opening ideas that
shocked really showed in this game and
they worked out well for him it is a
very beautiful game so I do want to show
you the entirety of it 97 94 we saw all
this 92 94 of course continuing through
now making use of this e4 square and now
white decided he needed to play a four
to kick this night off of this nice be 5
square Knight a 7 back was black's
choice white simply gets castled and now
this Knight comes out to c6 putting more
pressure on these white pawns which are
now advancing perhaps uncomfortably far
up the board b5 from white black goes
ahead and opens up this a file and now
like inserts this move Knight takes D to
this move could have been inserted at a
couple points but shock waited until now
to play it it's perfectly fine white
doesn't have anything better than to
recapture here if you take on c6 for
example well I'm just gonna take on f3
and take on h3 and then you're busted so
Queen takes d2 and now Knight b4 and
this idea from white is from black
rather is effectively winning the the
bishop pair here there's no real
comfortable way to to save this Bishop
you can play a move like Knight c3
perhaps but Knight takes D 3 is still
going to be playable here and yeah just
just no comfortable way to save this
Bishop you can't play Bishop b1 hangs
the rook on anyone and if you insert
this move and then play Bishop b1 well
you're giving up this pot as well so
black wins the bishop pair and this is a
common thing you'll actually seen there
it goes and is it's kind of
counterintuitive if you play Bishop
before threatening a night with your
bishop but in the end black is most
often the one that ends up with a bishop
pair due to this Bishop g5 Bishop takes
f6 move being so common but enough of
that and we'll continue on here with
Knight takes t3 Queen takes D 3 and now
Bishop e6 and what we see here is just a
very very comfortable position for black
and it's one in which I think black is
really playing for for the win here I
don't think White has too much to play
for there is this weak pawn on c7 there
is this e v square but in the end two
bishops are just always going to be so
strong in a position like this and shock
managed to show that in the game 95 was
played trying to make use of this square
but now f6 from black this is the proper
way to play against the Knights you take
away their outposts Nate c6 Queen d7
this knight on c6 looks nice but at the
end of the day it's it's not really
achieving a whole lot it's not hitting
any weak points and these squares aren't
particularly important for the black
pieces so we saw f3 from white and this
move is actually just a little bit too
weakening I think white perhaps said
grand intentions of playing efore but
we'll see those never really come to
fruition Queen f7 was played in the game
now of course if e4 we're gonna take
this and play Bishop c4 no matter how
you capture here Bishop takes seat
Bishop c4 woman and white immediately
kind of gave up on this efore idea and
continued through with f4 now black
actually chose to take on a 1 and after
takes on a 1 we saw Bishop d7 and the
reason black included this was because
he wanted to put pressure on the e3 pawn
and not have his rook be drawn away to
the a file so now it turns out white is
the one with the more relevant backwards
pawn White has no way to attack c7 and
black is doing very very nicely here
again continuing with rook a - and black
pulls out a nice idea with h5 king f2
and h4 sometimes it's good to just take
your space there's no real comfortable
way for white to try to win this pawn
immediately and so this is just going to
be a helpful attacker for black king g1
was played now g6 rook e 2 is over
protecting this pawn King g7 just
solidifies everything uses this King to
guard these pawns now Queen b1 Bishop f5
hits the Queen Queen d1 Queen e6 and
black has just improved his pieces
greatly here this Bishop is a monster
this Bishop is actually a little bit
caught behind this f4 pawn but we'll see
there's some latent pressure there
it also controls some nice squares on
the Queen side and after Queen d2 we see
rook a8 and together with this rook and
all of these pieces aimed at the King
black is just completely crushing rook
e1 was played trying to keep the rook
out but now rook a3 is still invading
rook F 1 is simply passing the time
nothing else for white to really do we
see rook b3 and I want to make note this
knight on c6 is not contributing this
game at all in fact it's a little bit
stuck on the c6 square rook' one now
from white tries to to invade but of
course black plays Bishop a3 keeping
that rook out now after rook a to Bishop
b1 there's nothing better for white than
to take this bishop and after rook takes
black has now given up this light
squared bishop in exchange for getting
this work to the first rank with a
devastating attack we see king h2 and
now Bishop c1 is getting at the base of
this pawn chain Queen e1 tries to hold
on via a pin and now black could of
course capture this pawn and go in for
just this totally totally winning
endgame but that's not really the style
of shocked mom and Yara of he plays
Queen e4 instead and after rook a7 I
encourage you at home to try and find
shocked mom and Yara idea here there are
there is more than one winning move but
I encourage you to find the idea that
shocked found in the game it's a fun one
yeah okay
go ahead pause the video now alright
I'll show it to you of course
Bishop takes c3 is technically winning
the game you do have to deal with some
annoying checks let's say King f8 Rick
c8 check King f7 or xt7 and at the end
of the day you are once again going to
be in a completely winning endgame of
course that was not shocked mama D ROVs
idea he's too cool for that he plays the
move Queen takes f4 and this is the
killer move that that shows really why
White's position is hopeless of course
you cannot take this piece Bishop takes
f4 and you have to play g3 to avoid
getting checkmated and
I can simply capture and check and take
this piece and now once again we do have
a winning end game but it's simply going
to be three pawns up for four black so
this is much more conclusive than the
other ones
so this queen is uncapturable king h1
was played in the game and now of course
shock mama DRF just continues to style
on his opponent plays the move Queen f2
says please take my queen white of
course cannot capture this Queen either
due to the same reason with Bishop takes
III when this Queen will fall now rook
takes d7 King age six is played white
tries Queen d1 to keep the game going
now of course shock mom and Yara of
plays Queen e2
please take my queen this time you can't
take not because you win the Queen but
because you get checkmated after a nice
little dance with this Bishop to the g3
square so Queen g1 was played and now
Queen takes III once again please take
my queen this time it's defended though
of course regardless Queen f1 and now
Queen f4 is forking White's major pieces
Queen d3 was played and rook a1 was
shocked simple solution to this
now the rook is hanging Bishop e3 with
mate is threatened and there's really
nothing to be done for white so a victor
went ahead and resigned this position so
a very fun game from shock Mahmud Yara a
very fun game for tregos and players to
look at once again the key points of
this game are one making use of this
night being on c6 threatening to do
things like play this move e5 that's the
advantage to having knight on c6 getting
this Knight drawn out with tempo is
going to help you control this Square a
lot faster other things to note of
course we don't want to trade this
Bishop on c3 and we do this nice waiting
move so we don't have to commit to
anything with our bishop then after
takes this Bishop d7 idea is very nice
to control this square and to prepare
this nice Knight maneuver not pawn b5
but rather night b5 and from there shock
manyara just played a very very nice
game in order to win okay let's take a
look at our third game for the day this
was a game between Tanya's octave and
metallic gloat of course tanya friend of
the saint louis chess club she's done
some commentary stuff for us but
unfortunately for her she ended up
losing this game to vitaly in this game
of course started with their gozen what
else would it be this class is about
there it goes in no supplies it's no
surprises here not Knight c3 but rather
Knight f3 was played d5 Knight c3 and
now Bishop b4 and from here we've looked
at Bishop g5 which is the most popular
move Queen I four check which is the
third most popular move now we're gonna
take a look at the second most popular
move which is of course C takes d5
solving this tension in the center
immediately black recaptures with the
pawn and now after Bishop g5 we have a
very similar position to the initial the
the initial game after age six and in
fact we could in fact transpose into
some of those lines with takes on f6
here but in this game we're gonna look
at the more interesting option for white
which is Bishop h4 this is going to
prove to be a much more exciting game if
rather than a much more exciting game
than the games in which white simply
captures on f6 and the reason for that
is black has a ton of interesting
options here the most popular move is
actually c5 immediately challenged
listen challenging the center but I'm
gonna recommend to the second most
popular move g5 because it's a lot more
fun to play g5 in the opening bishop g3
is of course White's only try and now
you have to play Knight e4 with black
this is the big idea you put a lot of
pressure on White's position immediately
and now there are a few moves that have
been tried here with white but really
the the only real move to worry about is
is Knight d2 white needs to challenge
this knight in the center pretty much
immediately or else he's going to risk
falling into a much worse position for
example if something like rook c1 is
played this move has been tried a few
times you're gonna run into
this idea from black h5 with a simple
idea of continuing on with h4 and that
would more or less be trapping this
bishop and this is a very awkward threat
for white to try to solve if you move
this H pawn anywhere
well we're simply gonna capture on g3
play the move g4 and this is not really
what what what what white is hoping for
on the Kings side here now there are
some tricky lines here with Queen a4
check and white challenging these pieces
immediately but black can just develop
simply with moves like Bishop d7 and at
the end of the day sorry not Queen a3
but rather Queen b3 this h4 move is
going to come through on the board and
it will probably prove to be a fun game
but I'm not gonna recommend you spend
all your time booking up on this it's
pretty unlikely that you'll find it in
your own games much much much much more
common as Knight d2 with a good game for
white I'm gonna recommend Knight takes
g3 you can take on c3 and go for this
pawn here but I don't like how much time
white ends up getting in this line for
example you cannot really take on e5 due
to this check and this square is now
covered so you have to like retreat or
go to b2 even and this this stuff just
gets a little bit uncomfortable for my
taste so I'm gonna recommend instead of
going for the pawn instead of being
greedy we take the bishop pair and true
grows in style that's kind of what this
opening is about for me getting the
bishop pair and trying to use it to your
advantage so H takes g3 it's the natural
response putting some pressure on aged
six and now things are gonna calm down a
bit from the craziness we saw with h6
and g5 and 94 you know we made all these
crazy threats against the bishop and
what did we gain for it well we we got
to take this Bishop off the board now
it's time to calm down and develop our
pieces so c6 from black defends this
pawn prepares to drop this Bishop back
and get developed with these other
pieces III from white makes sense Bishop
e6 is blacks choice you can come out to
the f5 square as well just to keep an
eye on this day
but there should be six make some senses
well help support this e six pawn for
any eventual c5 brakes you might think
about Bishop d3 does grab this diagonal
97 Queen c2 Queen e7 now a3 from white
and Bishop d6 and in this type of
position actually neither side really
wants to Castle kingside if white
castles King side he is really gonna be
in a world for her world of hurt after
age 5 and age for breaking open this
h-file and after white castles Queen
side as she did in the game if black
castles King side of course you're just
dropping this pot so both sides Castle
queenside and now really I'm gonna say
the only move for white here that makes
any sense to my eyes is this move Knight
b5 you need to take off this Bishop pair
for black or else you're gonna be in
some significant trouble King b1 has
been tried in some random game but King
V 8 and now this bishop is going to be
surviving and I like I like a blacks
position here quite a lot so Knight b5
King b8 makes a lot of sense break the
pen Knight takes T 6 Queen takes T 6 and
now King b1 stepping off this C file and
this is the position where I wanted to
kind of pause we're nearing the end of
the opening here in fact you could call
the opening over at this point and let's
take stock of what we have in this
position in which side we would rather
be so some notable features of the
position White's pawns over here are
doubled meaning black has this H pawn
and whereas white does not now this
could prove to be either an advantage or
a disadvantage depending on what happens
in the game of course if this pawn
remains backwards then white is going to
be too kind of white is going to be able
to stack up rooks against it and put a
lot of pressure on this backwards pawn
however if black can use it to his
advantage
perhaps pushing this pawn up the board
then it could just be a nice it could
just be some nice extra space on the
Kings
side or black other notable features of
the position of course there is a
another difference in the paunch
structure
weight has an e pon whereas black has a
C pawn here kind of the quote unquote
Karlsbad structure and what that means
in this position is that black is
actually going to be the one with a
little bit more freedom to play some
pawn breaks the reason for that is if
white ever goes let's say h5 as was
played in the game
if white ever goes for this movie for
well you're kind of running into some
weaknesses on this d4 pawn and this
Bishop being on the light square is
going to be unable to defend this pawn
and it's also going to give black this
very nice d5 square and all of this
means that white is not very free to
play this move
efore this isn't really a move white
once to play and so that's not a pawn
break for white whereas this move c5 is
actually going to be something black can
consider the reason for that being and
this Bishop supports this pawn very
nicely on d5 and it also allows black
some ideas of opening things up even
further with the move d4 expanding in
the center to activate the pieces so for
those reasons even though this position
is is likely just equal I really prefer
playing the black side here black simply
has more ideas than white and we'll see
in this game what kind of got shoehorned
into going after this H pawn and that
allowed blacks more freedom to play on
the Queen side and actually end up
winning this game so h5 of course is the
move to prevent this pawn from being
backwards and to continue pushing it up
the board tanya chose rook C 1 here
which looks a little bit strange but
perhaps was aimed at preventing this
move c5 and now black simply continues
with h4 taking more space on this Kings
side G takes h4 is natural for white to
undo the pawns and now Knight f3
puts more pressure on to this pawn now
there are actually still two games here
there's a game between some 2700 s
Nikita Petukhov and Alexander Moy Senko
and that game went h3 and the players
really didn't want to play a game of
chess anymore they they were ready to
trade off the pieces and go for a job
just to show you the game went G takes
h3 and now with these pawns traded off
the rooks come off white plays Bishop f5
and the bishops come off well one of the
bishops come off after Queen f6 and we
trade it for this night now Queen f5 and
the Queen's come off now Kings c7 rook
h1 king d6 rack age 6 king e7 and the
final minor pieces come off and and they
agreed to it draw but fortunately for us
we don't have to play like 2700 we can
still try to win some chess games
instead of Age 3
Natalia went for Queen e7 here
maintaining this pawn on h4 and I think
your white might already be starting to
get into just a little bit of trouble I
think it might be time for white to try
to bail out with a move like Bishop f5
and either taking on a6 or dropping back
to h3 just contesting this bishop on
this diagonal as soon as possible of
course this isn't really gonna be
threatening to the black player trading
off these bishops just brings the
position closer to a draw but there's
still some stuff to play for in the game
though Tonya went for rook h2 with some
ideas of doubling up against this pawn
and trying to win it outright Queen f6
was the nice hidden idea behind Queen e7
we're not just defending this pawn but
we're putting some pressure along this F
file as well
Tonya played rook C to H 1 and now H 3
is the nice idea by vitaliy to pressure
this Knight and force some uncomfortable
decisions for Tonya on this Kings side
91 was her choice stepping out of this
threat threatening to take on h3 and now
I'll let you at home try and find the
idea to get a significant advantage for
black and
see if you can find how to get a
significant edge here
for the black pieces go ahead take your
time don't wanna rush you but I am now
going to tell you the answer the move of
course is c5 and the point is after move
like D takes c5 let's say rook c8
hitting this pawn b4 we can play a move
we can start with something like H takes
g2 if we want and let's say and I take G
to trade off one set of rooks but the
point is Knight e5 it's going to be a
very difficult move for white to meet
and this is what I mean by black having
more options here black played on the
Kings side white diverted all of her
pieces over to this Kings side to kind
of deal with this age pawn try to win it
and this allows black to play both in
the center and on the Queen side of the
board as well black has this mobility to
switch between sides of the board of
course the problem for white is that all
of these pieces are lined up and it's
going to be difficult to prevent an
uncomfortable skewer from happening for
example if you play a move like can you
see one just to step out of it well
immediately you're stepping into
checkmating threats and if you play a
move like I don't know Knight h4 for
example just to guard this square well
we can do a variety of things including
bringing a rook into the game the black
pieces are just kind of walking all over
the white pieces here if you try
something like Bishop h7 to step out of
this well now Knight c4 is going to come
and really just blacks activity and any
move is as good for black and the white
King is really going to suffer so c5
would have been nice in the game
immediately in the game black chose the
slightly less accurate rook c8 but it
ended up being good enough for him
here I think you might be able to guess
the move I'm gonna recommend for white
in the game G takes h3 was played and c5
broke through on the board and blacks
still managed to get a nice edge so of
course I think the move b4 might have
been called for by white here just
putting a stop to these c5 ideas for the
moment giving white some more time
instead though we see takes c5 queen c3
from white and now rook h4 is the nice
move to force white to make a decision
about this pawn D takes c5 was played
Queen takes c3 and now Knight takes e5
and once again while black is
technically down upon the white pawns
are all pretty fractured and weak and
blacks pieces are much more active you
see these two rooks on the edge file not
really making a good impression stopped
up behind this h-bond the game continued
with Knight f3 and now rook takes h3 was
black's tactical idea takes takes takes
but now the bishop falls and white or
black has regained the pawn and all of
these pawns remain very very weak and
this was enough for black to convert
this position her cage 7 was played in
the game Knight takes f2 rook takes f7
94 hitting the c3 pawn 95 we simply take
rook d7 rook takes III and here
Tanya actually just resigned this game
was a pretty nice one by black and it
shows how even in the more equal lines
like this one black can still find a lot
of chances the bishops are always going
to be powerful pieces and it's normally
black who actually ends up with more
options here in this structure in
particular it allows for more mobility
of the pawns more options for black and
now I think I'm going to go over just
one more game super quickly for you guys
it's a game of my own that I played
between that I played against a 2000
youngster by the name of Alex Shang here
at the st. Louis chess club he's a very
talented kid I'm sure give him a couple
years so be much better than me but in
this game this one managed to go my way
and I just wanted to show you what a
practical game at a slightly lower lower
level looks like in there goes in
defense Knight c3 Bishop b4 Queen I four
check Nate c6 is the only move Bishop g5
and then I'm gonna be honest with you
here before this lecture I didn't know a
whole lot about there it goes and I did
a fair amount of prep to get this ready
for you guys and so I was playing this
opening pretty much unprepared in the
rigo's in defense and so I didn't know
what to do after Bishop g5 I wasn't
super familiar with this idea and in
fact it's not really the most common
move normally III is played and that's
the one that we looked at earlier but
okay after Bishop g5 age six I knew was
a common idea for black and it turns out
it's correct here and now white really
needs to take this Knight off on on f6
here but this is not what was played in
the game if this were if this was played
then the play would have continued very
simply much like the games we've looked
at previously where Bishop takes f6
happens but in the game white chose
Bishop f4 and now I'm going to try to
challenge you guys to find some
interesting ideas here for for black
there are a few really good options for
black in this position I chose one of
them perhaps the the let the least clear
of the ideas but it still ended up
working out for me
so go ahead pause the video try to come
up with some ideas I'm gonna introduce
them to you all right here we go
of course the move I played in the game
is Bishop d7 and this was a pretty
tricky move that I played actually and
it ends up giving black a nice little
advantage here I'll explain the point in
greater detail in just a second I wanted
to talk about some other ideas for black
the move 94 is also pretty comfortable
for black I don't think it gives as much
and it's Bishop d7 white would simply
play rook c1 here and then you can see
things like D takes c4 and Queen d5
actually is just an annoying way for
black to try to hold on to this pawn so
this is one way of playing for black
something like 94 taking this pawn off
the board looking for these Queen d5
ideas things like this are pretty
comfortable for black I think Bishop d7
though might actually give black the the
greatest edge here in the game my
opponent very naturally dropped this
Queen back to c2 of course there is a
fun tactic in there goes and after e3
simply Knight takes d4 is winning upon
you cannot capture this bishop
due to this check and getting all of the
white pieces and this discovered attack
of course is allowing black to capture
here so Queen c2 is played and now the
deeper idea behind Bishop d7 see if you
can find it what did I play in this
position here all right hopefully you
all found it at home already
the idea of course is g5 I started with
Bishop d7 to actually free up this
Knight I no longer have to babysit this
Bishop I'm no longer pinned so this
Knight now can challenge this d4 pawn
this is the idea behind g5 if white
plays them more comfortable
Bishop g3 you're gonna get hit with g4 I
mean no matter what you do I'm breaking
through and winning your tea floor upon
immediately so of course instead my
opponent plays the more testing Bishop
e5 I continue with g4 anyways I'm
bringing this knight back to d2 and now
I simply take on e5 and after takes on
e5 the idea is d4 and this is how I
first off won the bishop pair as I often
like to do when there are Gozen as I
said that's kind of what this opening is
about for me and secondly I gain some
very nice space in the center with this
move d4 and it's gonna be really really
awkward now for white to deal with this
the line taking on f6 doesn't really
work out well for white I can take on c3
and after you take back actually have
the very annoying move Queen takes f6
when you're all pinned up and this is
just gonna be really really great for
for black actually so instead I'm gonna
play the best move Knight d1 she's
trying to hold on to everything
now of course my knight is actually
attacked so I chose Knight h5 aiming for
some squares and my opponent played the
the slightly nonchalant III turns out
probably my opponent needed to play a
bit more quickly with something like a3
just evicting this Bishop immediately
from its b4 outpost after e3 I played
the simple move Bishop c6 improving this
Bishop to a better diagonal now a3 did
come on the board from my opponent I
dropped this Bishop back to e7
and my opponent now continued through
with the move b4 and it turns out this
move is actually just a bit of a mistake
Black is tactically winning by force
already here and I'll let you at home
try to find it I actually did not find
it in the game because I was a being a
bit silly and I was afraid of a move I
should not have been afraid of the move
of course is D takes III when after the
move Knight takes c3 Queen d4 is a
simple fork of these two pieces and
black is just going to be winning this
pawn as well as likely the the game for
some reason in my head I was concerned
with the move F take c3 which of course
is simply ridiculous
Bishop h4 check and this is why this
bishop on c6 is here put some very nice
pressure on this diagonal so the move g3
isn't really playable and this of course
is just totally totally crushing
something like King e2 now something
like Queen g5 and we're just we're
breaking through on on all fronts and
you can start playing some really fun
stuff here like Bishop g3 to at this
point but that's beside the point
I missed it in the game I played the
move Bishop age for trying to actually
just improve D takes III but my opponent
played the best move now b5 not really
giving me time to do all this I still
play D take c3 Knight takes c3 and now
Queen d4 and the move I missed in my
calculations of course White's best move
Queen side castles is actually saving
everything unpinning from this pawn and
saving the rook by moving out of the way
taking advantage of the fact that you
get to move to pieces at the same time
when you castle but it turns out here
black actually still has a nice
advantage after Bishop takes f2 my
opponent actually missed Queen side
castles in the game perhaps he didn't
realize it was legal I didn't realize it
was legal from afar so it's slightly
understandable now B takes c6 was his
choice but of course I'm simply winning
too many pieces here and the game
quickly resolved after a few more moves
I think maybe a few more moves were
played after this in the game but it's
not really worth looking at blacks just
up a full rook and the White King is is
in shambles so that was my introduction
there it goes and hopefully you learned
a lot about some common ideas for black
and feel comfortable enough to try it
out for yourself I definitely encourage
you to do so it's a very fun opening
it's one of the more active choices for
black against the Queen's Gambit rather
than going for you know your standard
Queens gambit declined positions where
it just ends up a bit boring and a bit
sad for black in my opinion so that's it
that's their goes and thank you very
much for joining me for this episode of
chess openings explained and I will see
you next time